straight from the core of the earth it  roars  pulsing and powerful it's a spectacle  not seen in half a century they can't  help but watch  but this old foe has consumed sways of  the island of las palmas it's divided  villages with putrid lava and swept away  homes miguel remembers the last eruption  50 years ago but says nothing compares  to this  it is not comparable to this one this  one has done a lot of damage the other  one didn't destroy anything nothing this  one is a disaster a disaster  even picture-perfect views are being  eaten away  days after its eruption cumbre vieja  continues to bubble and spit molten lava  into the night sky that unmistakable  orange glow consuming this town it could  be like this for weeks  and it could get worse with threats of  lava flows toxic gases and acid rain as  if this town hadn't been through enough